also darüber wollen wir sprechen das
phoenix nachgefragt mit robin alexander
heute journalist und buchautor und
stellvertretender chefredakteur der welt
ich grüße sie herzlich guten tag also
der deutsche weg geld statt waffen geld
für waffen würde der kanzler sagen
vermutlich aber es sind eben nicht die
richtigen waffen auf der liste sagt der
ukrainische botschafter andrej melik was
wissen wir denn genau über diese liste
diese liste verfolgt uns seit wochen wir
haben bei der welt maria ziert wie es
dazu kam und das war so dass am 27
februar schon sie erinnern sich dabei
die große zeitenwende redete von olaf
scholz und am 28 februar hat das
verteidigungsministerium die
rüstungsindustrie schon gebeten zu sagen
was könnt ihr liefern und diese
unternehmen haben natürlich die
dollarzeichen in den augen gesehen dass
es für die ihren riesen geschäft und
haben sofort angebote geschickt und aus
dieser industrie liste hat das
verteidigungsministerium
ministerium da eine liste gemacht die
sie für gut befunden als hat vor allen
dingen viel gestrichen dann sollte
dieser liste lange geheim werden diese
liste stand durchgestochen worden an
medien und die ukraine hat sie bekommen
am 30 märz und zuerst auf anfrage also
die mussten die tatsächlich in berlin
abholen haben wirklich gesagt ich
gelesen dass jetzt rückt die bitte raus
und jetzt haben wir den 19 april gestern
gehabt und jetzt sagt olaf scholz nun
haben wir diese liste und es ist schon
erstaunlich weil da sind ja wochen
verloren gegangen in einer zeit wo jeder
tag zählt jetzt geht es ja aber ein
stück weit auch darum was steht auf
dieser liste also wir hören bundeswehr
bestände sind erschöpft was kann die
industrie leisten also was was können
wir denn momentan überhaupt liefern
na ja also das ist ja immer diese
vorstellung dass deutschland mit waffen
nichts zu tun hat das ist eine ganz irre
vorstellung deutschland ist der
viertgrößte waffenexporteur der welt das
ist ja auch wie hart man kritisiert
worden also wir haben immer heftig
waffen in alle welt geliefert und die
industrie wie gesagt hat ihrerseits
diese angebote eingereicht und die
bundesregierung hat die schweren waffen
gestrichen die stehen nicht mehr auf
der liste sind aber vorhanden verstehe
ich sie richtig ja auch das ist wieder
so interessant die deutschland hatte ja
am anfang die position wir liefern
prinzipiell gar nichts ja das muss man
sich auch immer wieder vor augen führen
die waffen mit denen die ukraine den
russischen angriff zurückgeschlagen hat
vor kiew und anderswo sind geliefert
worden von kanadiern von briten von
amerikanern von anderen wenn der westen
sich insgesamt zu verhalten hätte wie
deutschland hätte putin diesen krieg
schon gewonnen und von dieser position
wären die fun prinzipiell nichts ist man
dann dazu gekommen wir liefern etwas
aber ganz schnell die
verteidigungsminister rind gesagt die
arsenale sind erschöpft dann wurde doch
wieder etwas gefunden dann wurde gesagt
also es wurde gesagt wir liefern nix
dann wurde gesagt wir haben nichts dann
wurde gesagt die industrie könnte was
liefern aber damit kommt ihr nicht klar
und heute morgen hat sigmar gabriel
immerhin ehemaliger vizekanzler
ehemalige spd vorsitzende das argument
in die debatte gebracht und man könne
keine panzer liefern weil in diesem fall
würde putin vielleicht mit taktischen
atomwaffen antworten also für denselben
sachverhalt wir liefern keine schweren
waffen wird jede woche die begründung
gewechselt eine salamitaktik die
natürlich unheimlich viel zeit kostet
sie haben jetzt eben die partner genannt
eu nato partner kanzlerschaft hat
gestern abend in seiner pressekonferenz
immer wieder betont es werde keinen
deutschen alleingang geben wie sehen
denn die partner deutschlands rolle da
im moment
ja das ist auch so eine erstaunliche
sache dass olaf scholz sagt kein
deutscher alleingang immer im bündnis
handeln das ist ja prinzipiell richtig
nur er sagt dann zum beispiel jetzt
sollen alte sowjetische waffen geliefert
werden aber wir sind ja in der phase wo
die partner schon modernes gerät liefern
also die amerikaner liefern artillerie
gegen die amerikaner liefern
hubschrauber das passiert ja schon das
passt nicht zusammen und gestern als
diese scholz pressekonferenz gehabt da
gab es etwas wie soll ich mal sagen eine
kognitive dissonanz weil um die scholz
pressekonferenz herum gab es nachrichten
agenturmeldungen niederlande und belgien
wollen schwere waffen liefern briten
wollen anti schiffs raketen liefern usa
kündigen artillerie an also das passt
alles nicht zusammen jedenfalls nicht in
der wahren wie kann deutschland das denn
jetzt wieder reparieren beziehungsweise
man man hat beim beim kanzler so ein
bisschen den eindruck der wille ist gar
nicht da der politische wille das zu
reparieren
das würde mir zu weit gehen aber ich
glaube dass olaf scholz gestern mit der
pressekonferenz nicht zur verdeutlichung
seiner und damit auch der deutschen
positionen beigetragen hat weil das halt
alles nicht zusammen passt schauen sie
heute lesen wir in der in der zeit von
einem kollegen der sehr gut informiert
ist im kanzleramt gebe es erwägungen die
italiener könnten liefern schwere waffen
und wir könnten dann sozusagen die
italiener wieder auffüllen aus
bundeswehrbeständen wenn das eine
erwägung ist sind auch wieder neue
fragezeichen weil entweder haben wir das
material oder wir haben es nicht dass es
dieses prinzip des ringtausch ist das
was was er gestern auch an westliche
partner herangebracht hat genau dann
stellt sich die frage warum macht man es
dann nicht direkt warum geht man den den
weg über dritte ich würde gerne noch auf
ein ereignis mit ihnen schauen was heute
an steht und zwar die reise der
außenministerin annalena baerbock die
reist ins baltikum
litauen estland heute lettland ist die
erste station wird dort auch hochrangig
empfangen wie steht das baltikum denn zu
deutschland was würde annalena baerbock
da erwarten die
balten haben uns all die jahre vor
unserer russland politik gewarnt wir
haben uns all die jahre gesagt diese
pipeline nord stream 2 ist und da liegt
kein segen darauf dass das wird alles in
ein großes unglück führen die haben uns
immer gewarnt und abhängig zu machen von
russischen energielieferungen also alles
das was jetzt so fatal eingetreten das
haben uns die baltischen politiker und
zwar rechte linke liberale wer immer
haben uns das immer gesagt und da hat
deutschland extrem an kredit verloren
frau berbalk ist allerdings in einer
besonderen position weil frau bernburg
ja schon in ihrer kanzlerkandidatur für
eine andere russlandpolitik stand für
eine realistischere russland politik und
auch die grüne partei in einer tradition
steht sie sich eben nicht mit russischen
wirtschaftsinteressen verflochten zu
haben deshalb glaube ich dass sie da im
moment genau die richtige person ist die
wir dort hinschicken können ok annalena
baerbock die richtige person für die
reise ins baltikum jetzt haben sie
gerade die andere seite aber auch noch
mal angedeutet die spd sie steht in der
kritik wegen ihrer jahrelangen falschen
hat sich
erübrigt falschen russland politik und
dann gibt es da noch diesen ganz
besonderen fall im moment nämlich von
manuela schwesig wie würden sie diesen
fall
einordnen in diesem ganzen spd
konglomerat
das ist kein reines spd thema da darf
man nicht unfair werden also die
russlandpolitik ist ja immer auch unter
der kanzlerschaft von angela merkel
gemacht worden und auch diese pipeline
nord stream 2 ist unter der
kanzlerschaft von angela merkel immer
weiter betrieben worden aber es gibt
tatsächlich ein spezialfall in
mecklenburg vorpommern das ist das
bundesland wo diese pipeline ankommen
ankommt und frau schwesig hat zur abwehr
von amerikanischen sanktionen eine
öffentliche stiftung gegründet die hat
sie klima und umwelt stiftung genannt
und in wirklichkeit war das eine
tarnorganisation mit dem dieser pipeline
bau fertiggestellt werden sollte um den
vor sanktionen abzuschirmen das geld
kann sollte von nord stream kommen also
eine firma die direkt über gazprom und
damit direkt aus dem kreml kontrolliert
wird diese leute sollten personal
schicken und wir von der welt haben uns
jetzt vor zwei wochen akteneinsicht
eingeklagt das ist nämlich ganz
schwierig da wird nicht rausgerückt und
da steht ungeheuerliche dinge drin so
hat zum beispiel diese nord stream firma
darum gebeten dass sie bei
hintergrundgesprächen der
landesregierung mit journalisten
heimlich mithören kann und die gespräche
mitschneiden kann und gestern hat der
innenminister von mecklenburg-vorpommern
ein herr pegel gesagt ja dieses in an
sinne haben wir abgelehnt und als
daraufhin ihnen die interviewer der
regionalzeitung fragten warum steht
davon nichts in den akten da sagt er ja
dass dieses ablehnen des mitschneiden
von journalisten gesprächen dass es
seines wissens telefonisch erfolgt also
das ist wirklich eine ein echter dicker
und dicker hund harte vorwürfe ganz
kurze frage zum schluss ist frau
schwesig ihrer meinung nach dann noch
tragbar als ministerpräsidentin
also dort stehen ja vorwürfe im raum ich
habe ja schon gesagt tarnorganisation
für eigentlich russische
staatsinteressen als deutsche stiftung
getarnt nebenaußenpolitik eines
bundeslandes und und und also wenn da
keine politische reaktion und auch keine
personelle reaktion erfolgt ja wann dann
deutliche worte fielen dank robin
alexander nach berlin gerne